never stop learning and we see
hello fresh every day is as a new
learning opportunity i think the moment
you stop learning and developing as the
moment in which the company ultimately
is going to stop growing and improving
as you want it to
[Music]
I'm voice I run the US operations
hellofresh hellofresh is an online
grocery delivery service we make it
easier for people to cook for delicious
recipes at home and we do that by
eliminating every single obstacle that
you have to home cooking our consumers
don't like going to the grocery store
don't like waiting in a line and they
struggle to find new recipes and new
ideas so we take all of those struggles
away from them by sending them a box
with the exact fresh ingredients and
step-by-step recipes and to make it
really easy and simple and so I joined
the the team at the very beginning and
to launch and run the UK business and we
started very early on in several
European markets and really kind of and
try to figure out the concept and how it
works and we had a really successful few
years in Europe and then over the course
of the last couple of years we've really
expanded in the US and so I went over to
run the the u.s. operation and now we
deliver over 9 million meals per month
globally the challenges of being young
and in such a rapidly growing company
and you know in in many ways he is more
of an opportunity an earlier stage in
your career I think you have the ability
to be very agile move quickly and an
adult and we've historically actually
hired people the trajectory rather than
experience level hello fresh and really
if we want to have a business which
evolved in gross and really defines a
new category on a global level we think
it's far more important that people have
an agile nimble attitude and to growing
the business I think my you know one of
my career highlights was actually came
before my career even started so i was
very keen sportsman as a teenager
growing up and then had a couple of
terrible injuries and those terrible
injuries led me to putting my
competitive intensity into
entrepreneurial endeavors and started a
couple of
businesses age 16 completely
unsuccessful but really gave me the the
entrepreneurial bug in the early stages
of developing a company from scratch
it's really all about hustling you know
when you going to corporate life people
have three months roadmaps they have 12
months strategies and you know in
starting a new business and getting
something off the ground and you don't
even have a one-day strategy so it's
really about kind of am focusing on the
imminent challenges ahead of you and
kind of really hustling and really kind
of making things happen
[Music]